the original Star Wars trilogy is
constantly evolving and that's not
necessarily a good thing now with the
arrival of Disney Plus we've been given
yet another version of Star Wars a new
hope the very first film in the
franchise and this version includes a
head-scratching change to our new hopes
most controversial scene the moments
when Han Solo shoots first or does he
now technically this new change wasn't
Disney's doing like all the other
perplexing Star Wars changes that have
been made since a special editions were
first release in 1997 this latest edit
is the work of crater George Lucas he's
still finding new groundbreaking ways to
rile up Star Wars fans all these years
after selling the franchise this was
confirmed in a statement that Disney
gave to comic book calm the changes made
by George Lucas prior to the Disney
acquisition meanwhile in a Twitter
exchange between a frog senior
entertainment editor Mike Ryan and
longtime Lucasfilm employee Pablo
Hidalgo Ryan tweeted I just watched the
new Greedo scene from the first Star
Wars was on earth
Hidalgo responded ah I see Disney
plasmus up the 4k version this would
have been done a few years back by Lucas
a final 4k restoration in anticipation
of a 3d we released that never happened
after 3d view Elisa's fizzled in the
latest version of the scene Bounty
Hunter Greedo utters a perplexing word
wiper Foy's him from a shootout with Han
Solo and that's really quite the doozy
but clunky thanks for clearing that up
there are no subtitles when Greedo
shouts a strange word even they were
treated to subtitles for the rest of
Guido's dialogue throughout the scene so
what does it mean exactly well slate
hopefully points out that McClung key is
a phrase use of the Phantom Menace which
is translated in the subtitles as it
will be the end of you if we have our
dates correct Lucas made this change
prior to selling Lucasfilm to Disney in
2012 but after the film's last blu-ray
release in 2011 that's a pretty small
window in the original cuts of the scene
the one that played in theaters in 1977
there's obviously no question that Hans
shoots first that's why he's slyly
pulling his blaster from its holster or
chatting up Guido natto
hon shoot-first hon only shoots Greedo
doesn't even get off a shot try putting
that on the t-shirt it's a cold-blooded
move but actually rather important for
his character arc since he becomes a
better man over the course of the film
well for the film's 1997 special edition
me release Luke assaulted the scene so
that Guido fires a shot to Han and
misses prompting Han to fire back in
self-defense
this chained absolves han of any
questionable behavior but one could
argue that it also makes his character
arc less compelling still George Lucas
doesn't see it that way at all as he
told The Hollywood Reporter in 2012 the
really upset people because they wanted
Solo to be a cold-blooded killer but he
actually isn't where do you stand on
this brouhaha following the release of
next month's Star Wars Episode nine the
rise of Skywalker the immediate future
of Star Wars hinges on Disney Plus
luckily for fans the streaming service
has big plans in store for the franchise
and you can stream the original trilogy
the prequel trilogy rogue one a Star
Wars story and Star Wars Episode 7 the
force awakens meanwhile the last Jedi
and solo a Star Wars story or hit the
streamer with current distribution
agreements expire Disney Plus will also
be streaming the rights of Skywalker
once the film leaves theaters right now
you can also stream the Clone Wars on
Disney Plus both the film and the series
all go nuts and stream Star Wars rebels
Star Wars persistance loads of Lego Star
Wars content shorts and documentaries
and of course the Mandalorian the new
series created by Jon Favreau
that's raking in rave reviews there's
also a live-action series in the works
that will follow the adventures of rogue
ones casseon and or as well as a
recently announced and long anticipated
live-action obi-wan Kenobi series that
will star you in McGregor reprising his
role as a Jedi Master after portraying
Kim in the prequel films in other words
the Disney Plus is shaping up to be the
go-to destination for fans to get their
Star Wars fixed for the next few years
until then may the force be with you oh
and one more thing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Star Wars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and to the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]